PROFESSOR: Hi, everyone.
So for the first
part of this course,
we've learned basically
the ins and outs
of solving linear
systems of equations.
Today we're going to do a little
review of the basic concepts.
Hopefully we'll see a few of
them in the following problem.
We're given a square
matrix A-- a three
by three square matrix A-- where
the last entry is a parameter
k.
And this parameter will vary.
And we'll see what happens to
the system of equations A*x
equal to [2, 3, 7], for which
k it has a unique solution,
for which k it has
infinitely many solutions.
Then we'll find the
LU decomposition.
And finally, we'll write
down the complete solution,
the system.
So I'll give you a
few minutes to work
this problem on your own.
And then please come
back and see how I do it.
All right, welcome back.
So let's start with part A.
For which k does this system,
A*x equal [2, 3, 7],
have a unique solution?
So what do we know about square
systems of linear equations?
They have a unique solution
when the matrix A is invertible.
So now, when is A invertible?
It is invertible when
it is of full rank.
And how do we figure this out?
We do it by performing
row operations.
We do it by doing
eliminations on the matrix.
But since we want to
simulate an exam setting,
it always pays off to see
what tasks lie ahead of us.
So in part C, we're asked to
find the LU decomposition.
This means that when
we do row operations,
we'd better keep track what row
operations we're doing exactly.
In particular, we'll write them
down as elementary matrices.
And in part D, we'll be asked to
compute the complete solution.
And therefore it's good
to do row operations
on the augmented matrix
A. So let's do this.
I'm going to write this.
The augmented matrix A is the
following beast, 1, 1, 1; 1 2,
3; 3, 4, k; and then 2, 3, 7.
So first thing, we subtract
a multiple of row one
from row two.
And it's exactly
negative 1 times
the first row plus the second.
Let me write down the
corresponding elementary matrix
that does this.
It's E_(2,1).
And it's lower diagonal
with 1's on the diagonal.
And it's going to
be exactly minus 1
in the first entry
of the second row.
So we get 1, 1,
1, 2; 0, 1, 2, 1.
And we copy down the third row.
Now we subtract a
multiple of the first row
from the third one.
And let me write this here.
Yeah, we'll multiply the
first row by negative 3,
and add it to the third one.
This is accomplished by the
elementary matrix E_(3,1) which
is 1, 1, 1, negative
three, and then 0, 0.
OK, 1, 1, 1, 2; 0, 1, 2, 1.
We copy the first two rows.
And then the third one
will be 0, 1, k minus 3,
and 7 minus 3 times
2, 7 minus 6, 1.
We have essentially one last
row operation to perform.
Let me do it here.
So we'll subtract the second
row from the third one.
And we'll get 1, 1, 1, 2;
0, 1, 2, 1; 0, 0, k minus 5,
and then 0.
And this was achieved by the
elementary matrix E_(3,2),
which was 1, 1, 1,
and then negative 1.
Because we multiplied the
second row by negative 1
and added it to the third one.
So we got to a matrix,
which is upper triangular.
And we want to figure out: for
which value of the parameter k
is this matrix of full rank.
This is a pivot.
And we want this one
to be a pivot as well.
And that happens when
k minus 5 is not 0.
So when k is different from 5,
the matrix A is of full rank.
And therefore the system
A*x equals to [2, 3,
7] has a unique solution.
Now part B. For which k do we
have infinitely many solutions?
So when are we in
such a situation?
We are in such a situation when
the null space of the matrix A
is nontrivial.
So the null space
will be nontrivial
when this k minus 5
number here, which
is what's the pivot in
the first case, is 0.
So k minus 5 equals to 0.
You see there's a
little caveat here.
When k is equal to 5,
we get the third row
of the augmented matrix,
0, 0, 0, equal to 0.
This means that the matrix
is actually consistent,
and we indeed have a solution
But if this entry were nonzero,
then we would get no solutions.
Now off to part C. We want to
compute the LU decomposition.
Well, we already got
what the matrix U
is through performing
row operations.
It's this guy here.
Let me write it down-- 1, 1,
1; 0 1, 2; 0, 0, k minus 5.
And when k is equal to 4,
this entry's negative 1.
And now what about the matrix L?
Well, how did we get to this U?
We had the matrix A.
We got the matrix U.
And what we did was
first we applied E_(2,1).
Then we applied E_(3,1)
and then E_(3,2).
We get A by inverting
this equation.
So it's going to be E_(2,1)
inverse E_(3,1) inverse E_(3,2)
inverse times U. And
this is our matrix L.
And we know it's fairly easy
to invert these elementary
matrices E. We flip the signs
of the off-diagonal entries.
I'm not going to
write down again
the inverses of these guys.
I'm just going to write the
product of the inverses.
And that's also very
easy to compute.
Because one, we
invert the signs.
We just send the numbers in
their corresponding entry of L.
I mean the following thing.
So minus 1 becomes a 1.
And it comes here, in
its respective entry.
For E_(3,1), we flip
the sign, first 3,
and we plug it in here.
And for E_(3,2), we flip the
sign of this guy, becomes 1,
and we plug it in here.
So give me a few moments
to erase the board,
and then I'll do part four.
We're back, and we're
going to do part D now.
So we need to find
the complete solution
of the system for all k.
And we saw that
for k equal to 5,
the system had many,
many solutions.
And for k not equal
to 5, it had only one.
So first let's look
at the case k not
equal to 5, when the
matrix A was invertible.
It's not hard to see what the
solution of the system then is.
It's going to be-- let
me just write it down.
So when k is not equal
to 5, this was nonzero.
Therefore, x_3 needs to be 0.
When x_3 is 0, we have
x_2 plus 2 times x_3.
So x_2 plus 0 equals 1.
Therefore x_2 is 1.
And then we go back
to the first row.
We have x_1 plus x_2
plus x_3 equals 2.
So x_1 plus 1 plus 0 equals 2.
So x_1 plus 1 equals 2.
And therefore x_1 is 1.
Good.
Now what about k equal to 5?
Then we see that x_3
is a free variable.
So the solution will
be [x 1,  x 2, x 3].
x_3 can be any number c.
From the second row, we'll
get the value of x_2.
It's 1 minus 2 times x_3.
So 1 minus 2 times c.
And x_1 is 2 minus
x_2 minus x_3.
So let me rewrite this.
It's 2 minus x_2
is 1 minus-- aah,
chalk-- 2c, minus
c, 1 minus 2c, c.
So we'll decompose
this vector here
into a component which
is independent of c
and a component which
is a multiple of c.
So this is 2 minus 1.
It should be [1, 1, 0]
plus c times--
we'll have two c minus
c, c, so c times 1.
Here we'll have minus
2c so negative 2.
And here we'll have 1.
And thus we get the particular
solution for the system
and the special
solution for the system.
We're kind of done here.
If you're at an exam,
you should immediately
start the next problem.
Good luck, and
Ill see you later.